come sto non sono mai stata meglio Ho
meditato e fatto yoga notte giorno
giorno notte 24 ore su 24 a volte anche
25 ho trovato una serenità profonda
ultraterrena qualcosa che non riesco a
spiegare e anche se riuscissi a spiegare
tu non capiresti per me un Massa
d'acciaio non avete il Marsala
primitivi
tesoro Io non ho più una casa io ho una
scusa un attimo devo aprire il mio
chakra
l'energia che scorre in tutto il mio
corpo bellissima sensazione organizzare
una cena per me va benissimo Basta che
ci sia Indian Food Hallo Google
adesso tesoro Vado a fare un massaggio
Ayurveda per ripristinare equilibrio
mente e corpo Namastè